les 10 et 17 mars date retenue pour
cette municipale partielle à
basse-pointe deux listes sont en lice
dynamique pour 3 avec marie thérèse
casimir yeux et ensemble pour réussir
basse pointe avec un patrick mariello
martinique la première donne la parole à
ces deux têtes de liste aujourd'hui
patrick mariano bonjour monsieur marier
l'eau oui bonjour moïse viol dont ce
scrutin un nom à peu près avant la date
officielle du renouvellement annoncé
pour les différents conseils municipaux
de france c'est une chance finalement
c'est une opportunité c'est une
contrainte pour vous c'est une
opportunité qui est offerte à la
population de basse pointe de pouvoir
enfin obtenir le changement qu'elle
souhaitait depuis 2014 pensez vous qu'il
puisse agir deux premiers tours
justement pour 2020 en tout cas nous à
ensemble réussi à basse-pointe nous la
prenons comme une opportunité par un
premier tour c'est une élection
partielle siat mais c'est une élection
néanmoins il ya quand même une nature ou
de 12 mois à conduire alors deux listes
sont en lice on a dix qui toutes deux
ont quand même un objectif commun
convaincre de se rendre aux urnes
premier enjeu la participation
convaincre d'aller voter
il vient quand même ce carnaval qui
brouille un peu les pistes qui
brouillent le message jolie en mai en
tout cas vous parlez de convaincre je ne
sais pas si l'autre l'iss sera en mesure
de convaincre dans la mesure je vous
rappelle que ce l'équipe en place qui se
positionne d'autres côté avec un bilan
un bilan qui n'est pas ou luisant et je
ne sais pas si aujourd'hui il ya lieu de
parler de bilan quand dans la mesure que
l'ia pratiquement pas de réalisations
visibles
néanmoins les pointois aspirent au
changement et j'espère que les habitants
de basse pointe vont se mobiliser pour
que le changement
auquel il est en tout cas qu'ils
aspiraient puisse avoir lieu le dimanche
au soir
le thème majeur de la campagne pour vous
patrick marielou pour votre liste c'est
quoi c'est permettre le retour de la
paix sociale abbas points c'est la
priorité des priorités
il n'y a pas que cela il s'agit aussi
pour nous de remettre en selle le tissu
associatif qui est désagréger
pratiquement aucune action ciation
aujourd'hui n'est capable de fonctionner
faute de mise à disposition de moyens
matériels et en l'absence de toute
subvention versée depuis le 23 mars 2014
quand vous parlez de réconciliation des
points 3/7 fracture s'est fracturé sont
visibles au jour le jour au quotidien
sur les trottoirs dans les quartiers
mais bien entendu ces fractures visible
et je vous rappelle
pour quelle raison que nous sommes ici
pourquoi je suis en interview parce
qu'il y a des points toi qui ont
démissionné du conseil municipal une
majorité de 22
on a eu neuf d'édition souci démission
il ya eu cinq adjoints sont huit
donc ne serait ce que dans un premier
temps les raisons qui ont conduit ces
personnes a démissionné et il n'y a pas
eu que 9 des missions il faut savoir
qu'il ya eu beaucoup plus de démissions
concernant cette équipe parce qu'il y
avait aussi une suite de l'iss qui a vu
la démission de deux ou trois personnes
vous avez mis en avant même le début de
la campagne officielle
la question de l'attractivité trop 2.3
son parti sont allés dans les communes
avaient environnantes que ce soit je
veux pas bouillon le lauréat wire ce
sera un des thèmes principaux de votre
communication
mais bien entendu l'attractivité aussi
commence par la réalisation de logements
et n'y a eu aucun aucun logement
construit à basse-pointe de 2014 à 2019
ça n'a jamais été le cas depuis monsieur
bédouins mais c'est la première fois que
nous nous retrouvons dans une
configuration de la sorte
et ce qui se passe dans
et communes voisines notamment du loret
et d'ajouts pas bouillon est liée à des
logements qui sont en construction 20 ce
qui fait que les pointois vont résider
dans ces communes je prends un exemple
ajoupa bouillon a vu une augmentation de
sa population de 250 personnes est
majoritairement 2.3 vous savez très bien
qu'en douze mois avant les deux
renouvellements de 2020 vous n'aurez pas
le temps de faire grands comptes grand
chose mais nous pourrions 1 tab est un
summum de projets concernant notamment
le la réparation d'un certain homme de
debaty communaux d'équipements communaux
je prends le cas de stade nous avons un
projet aussi de réhabilitation de du
boulodrome de l'espace des mains et de
la l'aménagement d'une maison des
associations
par ailleurs il s'agisse aussi ponot de
redynamiser le tissu associatif
patrick aime marier l'eau de la liste
ensemble pour réussir vos spots merci
d'avoir été avec nous sur les antennes
de martinique à premier à merci c'est
avec plaisir et rendez vous le dimanche
avec enfants pour réussir basse pointe